hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2015 german adventure and comedy movie
called help i shrunk my teacher
the movie begins with felix frontman a
young boy previously expelled from many
schools due to his behavior hastily
preparing for his first day at otto
leyon heart school the last school in
his neighborhood that can accept him
after getting lost in the old unused
classrooms of the building they make
their way to the principal's office the
principal dr schmidt gossenwein doubts
felix can pass the probation period but
let's improve himself
after sending felix to class 5b she is
confronted by school inspector henning
seeming reluctant to talk to him felix's
dad advises that if felix is scared of
principal schmidt he should imagine her
wearing funny costumes so he would not
be scared of her anymore
felix enters class 5b and introduces
himself to a boy playing with a drone
mario and his gang robert and chris
principal schmidt enters the class soon
after instructs felix to sit next to
ella and begins the math lesson
after class mario and his gang also
approached felix and explained that if
felix wants to join the gang he must
complete three dares the first being
breaking into an old haunted teacher's
room after dark
felix hesitates then leaves
however he keeps thinking about it and
decides to jump out of his window and go
back to school after dark
macholsky the school keeper heads home
while talking to an unseen figure
felix mario robert and chris who
witnessed michalski deduced that he is
talking to hold us teach bart's ghost a
former school principal who mysteriously
disappeared
felix then breaks through the sewer and
makes his way to the old teacher's room
turns out the room is full of foreign
treasures with a prominent painting of
an old man who is otto leonhardt himself
hanging on the wall
in front of the painting is an
interesting ball inside a concave
container which felix takes
he is not aware that the eyes of otto's
painting can move and watch his
movements
he waves at the window signaling mario
and his gang to come with him
however principal schmidt notices the
sound felix makes she gets curious then
follows the source of the sound
she catches felix scolds him and tells
him his probation is over and he is
expelled from the school
she also realizes felix is hiding
something and demands it back which is
the ball
after putting the ball back into place
she continues scolding felix but felix
closes his eyes and imagines her in a
ridiculous situation as his father
advised so he would not be scared
the ball magically spins on its own
slowly at first but getting faster until
the container produces a bright spark
felix opens his eyes puzzled because
schmidt seems to mysteriously disappear
turns out she is shrunk to a very small
size and she is confused as well
she panics as mario and his gang enter
the room and hide inside felix's
backpack carried home by felix
the next morning felix is startled to
find trunk schmidt on his bedside table
he explains that last night he wished
her to be small so he would not be
scared of her scolding him then attempts
to wish her back to normal size again
while making breakfast but it does not
work
he tries to hide schmidt from his father
by putting her inside a sandwich and
quickly rushes to school
at school inspector henning accompanied
by michalski is seen bringing guests
into the old teacher's room
the guest is a wealthy family with twin
girls he plans to convert the old
teacher's room to a parent's club room
and throws all the treasures left by
otto the twin girls inspect the magic
ball and it suddenly bursts fire
michalski uses a fire extinguisher that
releases foam to all the family in
inspector henning
at the door felix wants to get in but is
surprised to see there are people
already in the room
schmidt gets angry at the scene and
instructs felix to confront inspector
henning bringing a message from her that
he has no premises at this school
he replies that mario his son is about
to move out from the school and the
school will be closed because it lacks
enough students the guests then leave
the room
felix asks schmidt what is going on
she explains that the school will be
closed then reopened as an elite school
felix argues that she is only one
student short and the school will be
saved from closure if she admits him
she refuses still complying with the
rules that felix must pass his exams in
probation period
realizing that his principal actually
needs him felix demands her to help him
in his math exam by putting her inside
his pencil case he promises to return
her to normal size again after she helps
him during the math exam mario gives
felix the secondary which is for felix
to do all of his in his gang's exams
felix insists that schmidt helps him and
she seems to truly help him
after school he talks again to her near
the school exit unaware that ella is
secretly watching him as she gets
suspicious of his behavior from the exam
she follows him on his way home he falls
while riding his skateboard and ella
discovers that schmidt sank then helps
felix to restore her to normal height
again
they go to the old teacher's room and
try to reconstruct last night's
situation but to no avail
felix realizes the magic has something
to do with the mysterious ball
schmidt explains that she might have an
explanation for the magic ball at her
home as she loves collecting old books
and manuscripts meanwhile in mario's
home inspector henning discovers that
the school admits one more student and
is planned to close the school might be
unsuccessful he wants to make an offer
with dr schmidt and quickly leaves in
schmidt's home felix and ella discover
that the ball can be opened and contains
ashes it suddenly shows a hologram
record of otto leonhart making a magic
elixir to transfer his spirit to the
school building they deduce that the
school is not haunted by holdest each
barth's ghost but auto spirit himself
the spirit protects anyone who dares to
harm or degrade the school in any means
that is why the attempt to make schmidt
return to her normal size is
unsuccessful because she has done
nothing to prevent the school from being
closed after talking with felix and ella
she also realizes that she is hated by
almost all of the students and other
school stakeholders
the next day felix and ella deduce
otto's plans for the school that he
wanted to make learning at school to be
fun just like a playground there are old
maps showing underground rooms which
each represent a subject such as math
and geography schmidt rejects the idea
that learning can be fun
at school the math exam results come out
and felix surprisingly got a d while
mario and his gang all got an e
frustrated mario confronts felix and
takes felix's possessions including
schmidt inside his bag
felix and ella go into mario's house to
retrieve schmidt with their clever plan
they successfully retrieve schmidt and
escape from mario they quickly head back
to the school to stop the conference
which decides the school's closure at
the school inspector henning concludes
the school must be closed which is met
by shock from all of the teachers
felix interrupts the meeting delivers
the letter of his acceptance which has
just been signed by schmidt however
inspector henning is not sure if it is
truly schmidt who signed the letter then
tears it to pieces he argues that
schmidt has long abandoned the school's
fate as he presents schmidt's successful
application in the school authority
felix and the teachers are shocked then
inspector henning leaves
however when he passes through the old
teacher's room he meets schmidt and he
is shrunk as well
the floor under them opens up and they
both fall into the deep
meanwhile felix is still disappointed
about the situation refuses to help ella
fine schmidt and leaves
ella single-handedly attempts to save
schmidt heads to the basement and
discovers a passage but she is caught by
mario and his gang at home felix
realizes he should not leave anyone
hanging so he goes back to school to
find ella he meets mario and his gang
and tries to explain what is at stake
ella presents an audio record which she
takes at mario's home showing that mario
admits the school will be closed and
transformed into an elite school and
only elite kids will be admitted robert
and chris not coming from an elite
family are disappointed then decide to
join ella and felix they discover the
secret passage in the basement and are
about to go inside as mario returns and
joins them as he is worried about his
missing dad
turns out schmidt and inspector henning
are trapped inside a room with the
school cat threatening them
the secret passage first leads into the
geography room
felix ella mario robert and chris solve
the geography riddle then the door to
the next room opens
the next room is math then they work
together again to open the next door
through the pipe felix communicates with
schmidt and confronts her about her
application at the school authority
schmidt admits that she applied a long
time ago before the school is about to
be closed after solving the math puzzle
they successfully save schmidt and
henning then head back to the old
teacher's room after vowing to not close
the school schmidt and henning are
returned to their normal size the school
is reopened the secret learning
playground is discovered and revamped
and felix is finally accepted into the
school
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching